so Gerard tell me about working with
Megan this was your first time working
with a animatronic puppet real yeah
creation well it was it's it's like as
my only my second movie I'd have to say
it was a bit of a naive undertaking
really you know I it was just such a fun
concept that I didn't really think about
how challenging it was going to be to
bring this thing to life that we don't
quite have the technology for yet but we
will uh you know maybe in five or ten
years time and so yeah it was really it
was hard but it was also you know
rewarding and fun and I think uh the
design of the doll was really the Saving
Grace like she just looked so like
hypnotic and that that did most of the
work for us I think yeah it's a Bonkers
movie was that kind of the goal was to
make it kind of
I the only word I can just use is Bunker
yeah well you know the world already has
ex machina that very slick stylish
meditation on artificial intelligence
and I love that movie but that that kind
of movie exists and I guess this is
really
um it's a lot more uh offbeat you know
and it's not like I'm you know I didn't
want to make uh anything like Chucky or
Child's Play because that's also been
done it's like we've had you know the
the real fun campy Goof Off version
um and this is just somewhere in the
middle of those things that it's really
fun uh it's self-aware and uh it's
offbeat and that's really that's those
are the flavors that I like the most
yeah because it's both it's both scary
and it's funny yeah right cool cool I
will thank you um that that you know
that it is a challenge to try to be both
of those things but it's so rewarding
when you send a room full of people and
they're laughing and screaming and
reacting audibly like it's just the best
feeling and so although I never really
thought about embarking on a career like
I've made two horror films and I love
all genres but I would say that that is
the really fun thing about horror
comedies is that you're just getting The
Best of Both Worlds you know getting the
laughs and the screams so do you see
yourself as a horror director now or no
but I'm it's I'm not snobbish about it
like it's fun it's really it's a fun
genre to work in but no I never really
set out my first film housebound it was
more just it was a it was a funny idea
that lent itself to being a horror movie
but that meant I had to really go to
school on how to make those movies
because I I learned that they're really
hard to make you have to have a real um
understanding of your craft and do
because so much of it the cameras
helping to tell the story and evoke
tension and things like that so it's a
real it's a real art form and I wish
um more people kind of um
understood that what goes into making a
really good horror movie so what are you
working on next oh
um well there's talkaver sequel but
we'll have to wait and see
um so there'll be that and yeah
um uh who knows uh there's a there's a
few things
um in in the fire but you you have to
have a few irons in the fire because
it's it's never up to you what kind of
gets picked up so yeah so a lot of
different things